good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that great thing that you have
inside you explode out into the world
and have a big impact so to help you on
your journey today's message is learn
from failure over to you Tony Robbins
[Music]
failure is part of life I mean the
difference for me though is I like a
failure as a stepping stone to success
it's a speed bump I know I'm gonna fail
but it's not failure if you learn
something and so gosh I've made so many
mistakes I've screwed so many things up
but every time I do it just becomes it
becomes a way for me to explain to
someone else what it takes you know it's
like here's what I've done I think I
have the ability to influence people
because I talk about my failures I talk
about all the things that messed me up
but I show people that didn't let it
stop me and you don't need to stop you
and I think I think that's really the
secret matter and if everything you
touch was successful first one you got
to relate to people as much oh you'll be
late and also it's be total bullsh and
everyone know it's both and also you'd
be bored silly I mean think about it if
you just said I want this to happen I
want this to happen you know people
don't value it they don't fight for you
know it's like you see kids sometimes in
it you know your parents will say you're
not gonna value this if you don't work
for it and you're keeping going
value just give it to me yeah but it's
true you know about things we've worked
the hardest for we value the most so I
think you know the purpose of the goal
is not getting it anyway the purpose of
goal you know is what who you become who
you becomes gonna make you happier kind
of make you sad so I'm not looking for
an effortless approach there's no such
thing it's time to change your mindset
around failure how you perceive failure
will ultimately decide how successful
you will become or how small you
continue to live your life and run your
business you need to understand that
successful people fail more than anybody
else that may sound a little bit
counterintuitive so say it again
successful people fail more than
everybody else you might be thinking
well how to successful people fail more
right if they're failing so much Howard
having so much success because a lot of
it is a numbers game the more you fail
the more you learn and the more you
learn the more you understand how to
make it a success too many people try
something and then realize after one or
two or three attempts oh this isn't for
me I suck I didn't make it the first
time and so I'm gonna quit
how many times did that happen now if
you try something and you don't love it
and it was an experiment that's great
that's a good failure so good
understanding you know not to do that
again but if you really love doing it
and you just can't produce the results
yet that's okay because you suck at
anything at the beginning and you need
to fail and fail and fail and fail and
so you get better whoever you love
whoever Tony Robbins or whoever it is
that you look up to they failed so many
times they failed more than you even
tried successful people fail more than
unsuccessful people even try if you look
at my youtube channel you guys are
friends that you're watching this video
I've tried so many series that have
failed that haven't worked that haven't
pulled in the numbers that didn't
resonate with people that we abandoned
that we quit that we we left
we've tried more series and most
youtubers even try even attempt and
eventually some of them work right like
the top 10 series work the ants wrestle
series work the mentor me series worked
to find a few that work and take off and
you can really leverage we had to go
through a lot that didn't work and it's
only through those failures that we
ended up becoming successful and it's a
never ending game I'm constantly
launching more series trying testing
scene does this work this does not work
I look at people come into the studio
and try to learn salsa dancing and some
people have always wanted to dancer they
want to meet friends they want to
connect they want to do some kind of
activity and they may not get to move
the first time right when I first
learned salsa I wasn't getting all the
moves perfectly the first time it's
through practice it's through repetition
it's through trying things and failing
them it doesn't work and then you learn
you learn from that and you get better
and you get better and you get better if
you're not failing then you're never
gonna win if you're not feeling and
you're just staying so small that you
never test anything out and you're gonna
constantly stay small there's nobody who
hits a hundred percent every single time
to go out and so I would strongly
encourage you if you don't believe me if
you're
and a hard time with this message I
would strongly encourage you to look at
whoever it is that you love and respect
and look up to and look at their career
look at how they started look at their
middle point look at where they are now
there's still tons of failures along the
way whether they were I was like massive
failures or lots of little micro
failures in little things and
experiments that they did even now your
heroes are failing consistently every
day trying something new trying to get
better because that's where the growth
comes if you're not failing you're not
growing which means you're not learning
and you never understand how to build
something that is super successful
so the question date today is I'm
curious what's the biggest failure that
you have learned something from share
your thoughts down the comments below
I'd love to hear from you and I think it
could inspire other people who are
watching this video as well I also want
to give a quick shout out to Thelma
Saunders Thelma thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and tweeting about it as well I
really appreciate the support and I hope
you enjoyed the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot event spresso
[Music]
you think about your risk tolerance for
failure how far are you willing to fail
well I mean unfortunately unfortunately
I felt quite a bit you know but I
understand that's actually part of the
process of succeeding I'm not one that
really believe in failure I believe you
have setbacks and you know you have to
learn from those you have to learn what
are those landlines that can be avoided
the next time what are those pitfalls
you have to learn from that stuff so
yeah welcome those things it's a part of
life but are you prepared to like really
fail it's something totally new like
what if you're just VC Dunamis VC yeah
you know and then I work at it and then
I'm not a PVC the next yeah you know
whenever it happens yeah this is not my
first year in league on national TV 18
years old not shot five straight air
balls in the playoffs in front of
millions of people yeah I think my time
is pretty high yeah ya think I'm alright
right obsessed with praise and success
and box office and stuff and I I think
for some reason I was just lucky that I
wasn't obsessed with that stuff cuz I
know a lot of actors that are and yeah
and I'm so thankful that I don't have
that gear to like be on box office mojo
in the morning after a project comes out
but on the other side I've been a part
of some pretty massive failures and I I
just don't really care I mean it's a
lover of course I would want every movie
I've been a part of to make a hundred
million dollars and that would be so
great and everybody would win but I
don't let the success of a project or
the lack of the success of a project
which many have not made a lot of money
take away from the experience I just
think the experience is so much we are
important and I'm I I I strive to stay
in that headspace because it's not
natural of course you want all these
things as a greedy human being but I
always remind myself like hey guess what
doesn't matter anything other than the
people you're in the room with what do
you do when you start a business but it
fails well hopefully you can learn from
all the mistakes all the good things and
all the bad
and reapply it to your new business or
reapply it to your new job or your new
career destination look at Apple Apple
is one of the most prestigious bankable
companies in the world and they had a
lot of failures they had a lot of
launches that didn't work they had a lot
of things that just didn't click with
the audience and their customers but
that didn't stop them from having a
thriving business you learn way more
when you fail than when you succeed if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details